(pigs squealing)
- When I was in the coal industry,
it was feast or famine.
Everything's going great
since they've shut down.
I've got some eggs, man.
Yeah, I went from working
in a coal mine, blowing up
the mountains, and now I'm
planting stuff on top of it, you know?
Reclaiming it back.
(violin music)
(piano music)
My name is Chris Farley,
and I'm a farmer for Refresh Appalachia.
(sheep bleating)
It's okay, buddy.
Refresh Appalachia has
come to these abandoned
surface mines and we're turning
them into active agriculture, farms.
This one will probably get
to be about five feet tall.
Everything you see here
was once an active coal mine.
What are you doing buddy?
Ay-yay-yay.
- And the way I like to do it is
just kinda step on it and wiggle it.
- [Chris] And almost everybody that works
for Refresh Appalachia was
a laid-off coal miner.
We have chickens that fertilize the soil.
We have goats that eat the tops
off the bushes.
And we have the hogs that come
in and they're like a plow.
They tear up all the rocks and the soil
and get it ready for plantin'.
(orchestra music)
This soil is so tough,
we have to use pick axes,
slate bars, just try to break it up.
It's tough.
Perfect.
I started in the coal mines
right outta high school.
(guitar music)
I just followed in my father's footsteps.
I used to work on the surface mines,
for over 11 years, similar
to what you see back here.
The first six years was good,
and after that it was every six months
to a year I'd get laid off.
Times were real tough.
Garden looks good.
How much rain have you had down here?
My grandmother and grandfather
had a farm their whole life.
They went through the Great Depression.
A picture of my grandpa.
They didn't struggle at all,
because they had their own farm.
Hey Gran, how was the
sweet potatoes this year?
- Last year they were really good.
- My grandma, she's old
but she's taught me a lot
about gardening, and that's
something I've growed [sic] up loving.
Yeah, I started out farming,
went into the coal mines,
now I'm back to farming, back to my roots.
We'll have this bunch come in first,
and then this bunch will come in.
If I had an offer to go back
into the coal mines right now,
I definitely wouldn't take it.
I'm hoping that we can have
the strip jobs workin',
and we can come behind them, plantin',
like we're doing right now.
There's opportunity there.
We can work together, and make it happen.
(guitar music)